Talk about a multiverse of madness. Sony
Pictures Animation's sequel "Spider-Man:
Across the Spider-Verse" not only breaks
new ground in the superhero genre,
but it also breaks the understanding
of the Marvel multiverse at large.
As seemingly established in "Spider-Man: No Way
Home," all Marvel movies — at least those in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and those released by
Sony Pictures — co-exist in the same multiverse,
with every iteration of the titular
web-slinger just a spell away from one
another. While "Across the Spider-Verse"
doesn't violate the guidelines set in
previous Marvel multiverse romps, it
does build upon them in ways that could
affect the MCU's defining multiverse
project — the Disney+ series "Loki."
"Loki" Season 2 is set to premiere in October
2023, and Season 1 outlined how the multiverse
works, grows, and is maintained across all Marvel
properties. Its mind-blowing first-season finale
casts some doubt on the stringency of these
rules, as the mastermind behind the multiversal
maintenance turns out to be an unstable Kang
variant known as He Who Remains. Where "Loki"
pulled the rug out from audiences in terms
of their understanding of the multiverse,
"Spider-Verse" introduces new rules
that are seemingly unimpeachable,
especially in regards to the film's
defining mechanic — canon events.
A canon event is a moment in a Spider-Person's
lifetime that is consistent across all variants
in the Spider-Verse and cannot
be changed without risking total
universal destruction. This includes
tragedies like the death of a loved one.
"And then I looked at my uncle and…"
"Uh, let me guess. He died?"
When this concept is explained at the
Spider-Society headquarters, a hologram
shows an image that looks similar to "Loki's"
branching representation of the multiverse.
Interestingly enough, an eerily similar
concept is introduced in the Disney+
animated series "What If...?,"
referred to as "absolute points."
"The power required to break an
absolute point in time is immense
and nigh impossible to obtain. Yeah, no doy."
The first absolute point delineated as
such is the death of Christine Palmer in
the episode "What if... Doctor Strange
Lost His Heart Instead of His Hands?"
Over the course of the story, viewers
see that absolute points are nearly
impossible to change without some
sort of multiversal intervention.
When Doctor Strange Supreme manages to do just
that, his world begins to dissolve into blackness.
In "Across the Spider-Verse," Miles
Morales inadvertently shows fans what
a decaying universe looks like when he
saves the life of the police captain
of Pavitr Prabhakar's Earth-50101.
The eerie, all-consuming blackness
bears a resemblance to similar events in
"What If...?" and "Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness." This could mean that
in every universe, what audiences see is the
inter-universal apocalypse known as an incursion.
What is an incursion? Take it away, Reed.
"An incursion occurs when the boundary
between universes corrodes and they collide."
By violating the boundaries between
universes, Miles and Doctor Strange
unintentionally altered canon events,
or absolute points if you will. Though
this newfound specificity is small, it
creates guidelines that, going forward,
could change how heroes and villains deal with
the Marvel Universe's newest overarching threat.
"Spider-Verse" also presents a key that could save
the fate of the entire Marvel
multiverse in the near future.
"You say the fate of the
multiverse and my brain dies."
Until "Across the Spider-Verse," there
were only a handful of beings capable
of traversing the multiverse intentionally.
Now, there is a possibly infinite number of
Spider-People that possess the ability to travel
the multiverse and seemingly prevent incursions.
As seen on Earth-50101, Miguel O'Hara and his team
are able to keep the blackness at bay by arriving
on the scene immediately. This is a skill that
neither Doctor Strange nor "Loki's" TVA have been
able to pull off. As the second season of "Loki"
continues to explore and elaborate upon how the
multiverse works, it will likely come up against
the subject of incursions and how they are caused.
That could lay the groundwork for Loki to
discover a way to prevent incursions himself,
thus staving off the inevitably messy aftermath of
Kang's meddling in the multiverse. It would be a
fitting end to the character's story, as he learns
how to maintain order without the quasi-murderous
ideologies of Miguel O'Hara and He Who Remains.
Instead of pruning, Loki could stimulate growth.
"Big metaphor guy. I like it.
Makes you sound super smart."
Narratively, a focus on growth would be the
polar opposite of The Infinity Saga's ethos,
which communicated that victory demands
sacrifice. As skillfully as this message
is conveyed, it would be fitting for
the new era of the Marvel multiverse
to usher in something different by
embracing the ability for comic book
stories to evolve beyond reader's wildest
imaginations, without all the nihilism.
The perfect place to set up this
much-needed shift would be in films
like "Across the Spider-Verse" and TV
series like "Loki," which tell stories
about the wonders of expanding worlds and
the potential beauty of creative evolution.